she's gonna say it I'll just say hello
I'm Keira Knightley and you're gonna do
all the difficult there okay isn't it
yeah I'm just passing it on over to you
hi I'm Mackenzie Foy and I'm Keira
Knightley and we're doing the wired
autocomplete interview does Keira
Knightley sing I have some I sing in the
shower most days does Keira Knightley
have a baby yeah I do
what's not really baby anymore-- tomalak
III hapax three does Keira Knightley
have an Oscar no two nominations she
will have one thank you
always the bridesmaid never the bride it
does Keira Knightley have siblings yes I
have one older brother who does Keira
Knightley end up with Shirley in Love
Actually I mean I'm with my husband I
would she would tell therefore yeah can
you see that once with and it was a
really long time ago am i yeah thanks oh
I don't go off without you Lincoln no
I'm with you at Elijah for oh it's me do
I'm holding it is Mackenzie boy related
to clarify no I don't know actually I
don't know it would be really cool
wouldn't it if you work related to
Claire for him yeah she's very nice
that would be really cool but you're not
I don't think so no was we can see fine
CGI life like are you a CGI creation um
well I think this is meaning in Twilight
cuz I played a character that was like
grew up quickly so I was part CGI and
some of them some of it was my real body
in another they put my face on somebody
else's body well yeah so you are
actually sees really what is McKenzie
for doing now right now I'm doing the
wired autocomplete amazing how all this
Mackenzie Foy I'm 17 almost eat
does Mackenzie Foy have siblings yes I
have an older brother who's very nice
I've met him he's really came to set
yes he's lovely no I got this more what
Keira Knightley doing now
Oh being less professional than
Mackenzie Foy because what am i doing
now the what Keira Knightley first movie
oh I don't remember I started when I was
six I think remember what my first movie
was I did Star Wars when I was 12 I
don't think that was my first one I
think I'd done one before that anyway
today what Keira Knightley playing Star
Wars see leading on to Star Wars
I played Queen Amidala's handmaiden
double what Keira Knightley real name
Keira Knightley what color how American
spelling is Keira Knightley's hair
American spelling yeah we've got a unit
of color not Keira Knightley anyway the
this color is my color have hair brown
brown solidly brown very grey in the
back whatever what languages does Keira
Knightley speak only one I only speak
English I'd like to speak more what do
you speak English English or a terrible
pair we need to learn another language
Mackenzie Foy what became Z Foy playing
by what movies do you play stunning what
the kids eat boy what's that number you
know what what's up this yes Mackenzie I
know I am a very much older person than
you but I do know what's happened wait
don't give you what's that certain
people do I don't know one though ooh
I've got it what's that then you don't
have a watch is that weird
should I not have a whatsapp well it
does McKinsey boy look like now
sure you look lovely with love cats and
blue did it it's very nice
thank you when was Mackenzie Foy born
November 10th 2000 that made me feel
really old this where keira knightley
house in Love Actually surely that's
where's Keira Knightley's house in love
actually but whatever Notting Hill I
don't know it was about 17 years ago but
I think it was Notting Hill London
London London London you spent lots of
time in London you didn't get much
Notting Hill working too much
where Keira Knightley grow up again
where did - Keira Knightley grown I
don't know Teddington outskirts of
London Teddy Teddy sounds so cute does
it
Ted Rosie isn't it country-ish not
really no it's a suburb it's quite nice
there's parks where keira knightley go
to college I went for three months -
Aisha College which is in a suburb of
London who Keira Knightley
look like well I mean who does Keira
Knightley look like oh come on
like what is Keira Knightley pronounce
her name once again how does Keira
Knightley pronounce her name shall I say
it again Keira Knightley Kieran a that's
how I pronounce my name is Keira
Knightley English no no from Mars yeah
yes I am English Mackenzie Foy does
Mackenzie Foy sing I do but it doesn't
always sound good what school does
Mackenzie Foy go to home school how to
look like I'm Kenzie Foy mm-hmm blue
eyeshadow today blue eyeshadow get a
blue eyeshadow yep very nice earrings
Benna mascara Raines braids how to be
like Mackenzie Foy
before I just hiccup and fall over a lot
oh you do hiccup and fall over a lot but
you don't just hiccup and fall over like
you're also completely brilliant so
you'd have to be completely brilliant
and hiccup and fall over a lot is that
it we done it oh that's good what did I
learn about you I knew that you had a
brother I knew you were home in the end
part CGI I learned that you're part CGI
yeah that's nice